hey everyone this is Vijay Master
Castillo Kavinsky here for chess calm
and today I'm going to be showing you
guys the ins and outs of the sloth
defense
so after d4 d5 c4 the Queens gambit
we've already covered how the play
usually proceeds if black chooses to
play six which is known as the Queens
gambit declined the sloth defense is
characterized if in this position black
chooses to play the move c6 so this is
sort of another form of the Queens
gambit declined but it's officially
known as the sloth defense the idea
behind this move c6 is very similar to
playing c6 if Y takes on d5 black is
ready to recapture with a pawn and
retain control of the square e for not
allowing Y to establish a strong center
this lot of defense is also a really
solid and classical opening if you're
looking for a good defense to one d4 the
Slav is definitely an opening you should
consider as you're going to get all of
your pieces out have good control over
the center and not have any weaknesses
once you get out of the opening the main
difference between the Slav and the
Orthodox Queens gambit declined where
black plays c6 on move to is that black
doesn't immediately block in this light
squared bishop and this is important
because in most d4 openings
blacks main problem especially in the
Queens gambit declined is figuring out a
way to develop the bishop on c8 it's
usually not easy to find a good square
for that Bishop where it can play an
active role in the game so here white
pretty much has two options he can
develop one of his knights either Knight
f3 or Knight c3 and then after Knight f6
develop the other night and this is the
most classical way to meet this love
just developing the pieces and white
also has another option here to play C
takes d5 and after black recaptures this
variation is known as the exchange
Slough because of the exchange of the
pawns on the fifth-ranked and I would
recommend players facing this line as
white to play this way only if you're
not looking to study a whole lot of
theory and you just want to get a simple
position out of the opening in that case
this is a really good choice because the
play here develops very simply both
sides just develop their pieces towards
the center and the player playing white
is going to try to prove that his extra
tempo or the advantage of the first move
is going to be worth something but
honestly if black plays accurately and
sticks to general opening principles he
really shouldn't have any problems in
this line so a more ambitious way to
play this opening for white is to start
by developing your Knights and at this
point black sort of faces a small
dilemma the natural move here would be
to just develop this Bishop to either f5
or g4 but the problem with developing
the bishop this early is that it leaves
this b7 pawn undefended and white here
can immediately take advantage by
playing C takes D and queen b3 and now
black doesn't have a good way to defend
this pawn playing b6 we just weaken the
light squares and then when Y plays III
or even efore sometimes he's going to be
threatening Bishop b5 check which can be
really unpleasant to deal with with the
pawn on b6 playing Queen b6 here would
actually lose upon immediately because
of Knight takes d5 and if black trades
Queens then why has this move Knight
takes f6
check and after white recaptures a queen
he's going to be up a clear pond and
playing something like Queen d7 just
allows white to build a strong
initiative with 95 followed up with
Bishop f4 rook c1 pushing the e pollen
and then Bishop b5 and white already has
a very serious attack so because of that
the main move here is for black to play
D take c4 and the point of this move is
that while white is spending time to
recapture this pawn black is going to be
able to develop as bishop and white
won't have the b3 square for his Queen
to harass the b7 pawn I want to mention
that this isn't the only move black can
play here he also has two other really
serious options the first one is to play
a six and this is known as the semi Slav
opening I would say leads to a
completely different set of positions so
I believe it really just deserves its
own video so I won't be covering that
today the other options for black to
play a6 which is known as the chameleon
Slav because this is a really flexible
move and it's almost a waiting move
because black just wants to see what why
it does first and then you'll decide
what to do with his Bishop but this is
another very serious opening and leads
to a variety of other positions that we
won't be looking at today but for today
I just wanted to show the lines after D
takes e4 and this is definitely the main
line of the Slav defense so now black is
ready to play b5 and defend this pawn
after which white will have a lot of
trouble winning his pawn back and we'll
have to play down upon so although white
here can try moves like efore or e3 the
most critical move here and the one I
would recommend is to play a four which
stops black from playing b5
so now black can play Bishop f5 and
again white doesn't have Queen b3
harassing the b7 pawn and here white has
a few different options the most
classical one III and then after ecigs
Bishop c4 Bishop b4 castles 9b d7 or
each a position that's really close to
being equal if anything maybe White has
a tiny tiny advantage here because he
has slightly more space and better
control over the center but blacks
position here is very solid and as you
can see all of his pieces are developed
and white is still unsure about what
he's going to do with this Bishop on c1
so I would say that black really
shouldn't have too many problems here
equalizing White's plan in this position
is to organize the advance III e4 and he
usually plays moves like Queen e2 to
make this happen in black after he
completes his development by castling
usually wants to break in the center
with either c5 or a 5 and challenge
white space advantage and those two
plans are pretty simple and easy to
remember and that's pretty much all you
need to know to play this line for
either side more complicated move here
is to play 95 wanting to win the pawn
back with the knight this way and then
prepare to immediately build a strong
center with E for sometimes supported
with this move f3 and then efore and
sometimes with g3 Bishop g2 and E for
this is definitely more ambitious way
for white to play and against 95 black
here has two main options here the first
is to play Knight B d7 and then after
Knight takes e4 black and try either
Knight b6 trying to get a solid position
in the center following this move with
moves like a v e6
before and castling and this line is
pretty similar to the line where Y plays
III on move six and black also has a
sharper option here to play Queen c7 and
this is a very dynamic choice and blacks
idea here is to strike back in the
center with E 5 in this line is quite
sharp but if you're interested in it I
definitely recommend you studying it
further because it leads to really rich
and interesting play for both sides and
blacks other option in this position
here is to play ecigs and now Y can
choose to develop normally with a move
like III followed by Bishop takes c4 or
if white is feeling more ambitious he
should look into playing this move f3
which I won't get into this video
because it's quite complicated but if
you're more interested in this line or
with the lines with 9b d7 on move 6 I
recommend you going to chess comm and
checking out the openings explore or you
can find a lot more information about
this line and go study it as deeply as
you'd like and why it's last option here
is this tricky move Knight h4 just
attacking the bishop and asking that
Bishop where it wants to go if black
plays Bishop g4 he's going to have to
deal with h3 and then if Bishop h5 then
g4 and White's gaining a lot of space
black has another option here just to
play e6 but eventually after white takes
his Bishop on f5 he's going to have two
bishops you'll be able to win this pawn
back on c4
after playing III and you'll have his
fair control over the center probably
black is okay in this line because the
pawn on f5 will be able to control this
efore square quite nicely and black will
have really good control over the light
squares which makes his position
playable another option is just to go
back
to c8 this move is basically telling
white that is nine on h4 is not doing
such a great deal on the side and
usually why will try to justify this
move by playing something like III or
efore and just leaving the knight on h4
for a little while until he develops the
rest of its pieces in the last move here
probably the most critical one is Bishop
d7 in here and some lines block is going
to play b5 and support is pawn on c4 so
that's pretty much it for the Slav
defense I hope they give you guys a good
introduction into the different
possibilities for both sides in this
mainline variation and if you're
interested in learning this classical
opening more definitely visit chess comm
for videos and articles and the use of
the opening Explorer which really helps
a lot with studying new openings thanks
a lot for listening and I'll see you
around on chess comm